[Musique]
c'est désagréable si jamais tu partirais
jeunes avec toi quand je sortirai jamais
avec qui n'ont jamais jamais jamais
mondial des milliardaires jadis avait
jamais vraiment comment
aujourd'hui
[Musique]
à la haye où je peux vous décidez de
partir avec moi jusque alors avec vous
je ne sais pas mais mais parce que je me
sens pas tellement aventurier dans l'âme
car eh ouais je sens une petite
faiblesse sais pas je vis de faiblesse
ouais je sais pas des mousses et avec
toutes les tailles et que je t'ai mis
connard
[Musique]
près du tiers du verbe qui est arrivé
fatigué
et donc le mien il annonce donc ils
disent avoir 3 dès 9h30 temps estimé non
pas qu'ils viennent plus c'est pas la
peine chérie donc vous avez la commande
regardez votre commande la commande de
kelly
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
me
bien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à